dangerous driving falling for the wrong
person and dancing with cartoon birds
these movies really tested the limits of
how much an actor could take
the dark claustrophobic sets and
constantly gushing water made for some
difficult days on the set of James
Cameron's 1989 sci-fi flick the abyss
but one day stands out for Mary
Elizabeth Master Antonio while filming a
scene in which Ed Harris performs CPR on
her Cameron directed Harris to actually
slap Master Antonio he had to repeat the
slop when the take was obstructed by
Harris's arm after the next take was
botched when the camera ran out of film
Master Antonio actually got up and left
the set she stayed away for hours
leaving Harris to practice with a
sandbag until she was ready to finish
filming the scene Captain America Civil
War focuses on the rift between the
Avengers as the US government tries to
limit their reach this new oversight is
partially inspired by the exploits of
the Winter Soldier AKA Bucky Barnes who
is being pursued by various factions in
an attempt to keep his old friend out of
Harm's Way Steve Rogers played by Chris
Evans tries to get to him before anyone
else can in a dramatic chase scene Bucky
attempts to escape by flying away in a
helicopter this prompts Rogers to try to
keep the powerful vehicle grounded with
his own two hands in an impressive feat
of strength he actually manages to bring
the helicopter crashing down however
filming this scene was so intense that
it left him injured speaking to ET
online Evans remarked and I actually
messed up my arm don't I really did
according to Evans this stunt wasn't
created through special effects he's
truly straining to keep this helicopter
under control he explained it's a fake
helicopter obviously but it was drifting
beyond the ability of control I tweaked
a little something to this day I'm still
messed up while on the set of the 2002
Thriller Panic Room director David
Fincher told the New York Times I felt
like I needed to be more attentive to
watching the actors he put that theory
into motion for his next film zodiac a
period piece about the search for the
Zodiac Killer who murdered their way
through Northern California in the 1970s
Jake Gyllenhaal who starred as
cartoonist turned crime reporter Robert
graysmith bore the brunt of Fincher's
commitment to putting his actors through
the ringer according to Gyllenhaal for
one scene Fincher required 70 takes for
another he asked for 90 plus because the
film was shot digitally Fincher could
spontaneously delete a slew of takes all
at once Gyllenhaal said but there is a
stopping point there's a point at which
you go that's what we have to work with
but we would reshoot things
although it was far from her first major
role Kate Winslet's performance in
Titanic launched her to worldwide
stardom but filming the movie was not a
pleasant experience the telegraph
reports that there were multiple issues
on set that caused both the cast and
crew to question whether they wanted to
remain part of the project at all
but these ship counts she's made of iron
sir I assure you she can one
particularly troubling moment came when
Winslet filmed a scene in the water
according to the times she genuinely
feared she might drown in the set's
gargantuan water tank things were so
rough she even expressed a desire to
steer clear of director James Cameron in
the future as reported by the guardian
Winslet said he has a temper like you
wouldn't believe you'd have to pay me a
lot of money to work with Jim again
years later however she's softened her
stance the pair collaborated on avatar
the way of water Quentin Tarantino's
Kill Bill movies follow Beatrix kiddo
AKA The Bride As she seeks revenge on
the deadly Viper assassination Squad
years earlier the group betrayed her by
killing her groom to be and putting her
in a coma now she's back on her feet and
ready to dispense Justice Uma Thurman
shines as the deadly kiddo earning
International Acclaim for her
performance in the second movie a scene
in which kiddo drives a car with Steely
determination proved to be problematic
as the New York Times eventually
revealed Tarantino pushed Thurman to
drive the vehicle herself despite her
well-founded concerns that it would be
unsafe those fears were soon Justified
when the car hit a tree causing serious
injuries that Thurman still deals with
to this day she revealed that
immediately after the incident she was
scared she would be unable to walk again
Thurman remarked I went from being a
creative contributor and performer to
being like a broken tool after a 15-year
battle to get footage of the crash
Tarantino finally surrendered it to
Thurman but as Thurman herself noted
this can't undo the damage that was done
or the pain that still lingers in the
1993 film What's Eating Gilbert Grape
Johnny Depp starred as the titular
Gilbert a guy stuck in a small town
caring for his developmentally disabled
younger brother and their housebound
Mother cast as the mom was Darlene Cates
an acting novice that director Lassa
hallstrom spotted on the Sally Jesse
Raphael Show discussing her own struggle
with obesity Depp was going through some
personal stuff during the film's shoot
and was using alcohol to cope hallstrom
later told Entertainment Weekly that he
also empathized with his character a bit
too much it was more that he could
relate to the troubled family life and
the desire to get out of a small town
situation Depp was in such a sensitive
place that he had trouble filming scenes
where the character had to make
disparaging comments about his mother
case recalled that each night after
those scenes were shot Depp called her
to apologize she explained he here he is
the professional he's done all this
stuff before but I thought what a
tribute to his kindness that he would
take the time to consider that I might
be hurt by what he said
shimmering armor
did you know that
to do his job killing bad guys and
foiling terrorist plots 007 needs to use
the firearm on occasion
[Music]
one of the actors who portrayed Bond on
screen had a really hard time with those
moments Roger Moore starred in 7007
movies including the spy who loved me
Moonraker and ironically The Man with
the Golden Gun while he doesn't regret
playing James Bond according to the BBC
Moore once said I regret that sadly
heroes in general are depicted with guns
in their hands and to tell the truth I
have always hated guns and what they
represent it all goes back to his
childhood in his Memoir my word is my
bond Moore said that as a boy he was
rendered deaf for a few days when a gun
blew up in his hands a few years later a
friend shot a BB gun into the future
star's leg when he'd have to use a
firearm on screen Moore would squeeze
his eyes tightly in discomfort as he
pulled the trigger on his prop Walther
PPK firearm by the time he filmed his
final Bond movie he publicly lamented
that the film series had quote turned so
violent in Quentin Tarantino's Django
Unchained Jamie Foxx plays Django
Freeman a formerly enslaved man who
joins Dr King Schultz to rescue his wife
from fearsome Plantation owner Calvin J
candy played by Leonardo DiCaprio as you
would expect from a Tarantino movie
Django Unchained contains lots of
stylized violence gory fight scenes and
plenty of foul language including a
number of racist slurs DiCaprio took
issue with his dialogue which required
him to use these ugly terms multiple
times as Metro Dakota UK revealed the
actor needed outside advice to move
forward with the brutal script both Fox
and Samuel L Jackson
urged him to perform the dialogue as it
was written for the sake of authenticity
though he did manage to move forward
DiCaprio said that he found bling candy
incredibly tough the actor remarked it
was this incredibly interesting horrific
character I mean there was absolutely
nothing about this man I could identify
with the psychological horror film Black
Swan is memorable for many reasons it
was a huge box office hit earning more
than 300 million dollars against its
budget of 13 million dollars it also won
a vast array of awards including five
nominations from the 2011 Oscars Natalie
Portman Stars this promising ballet
dancer Nina Sayers who struggles to cope
with the demands of portraying the Dual
role of Odette and odile in
Tchaikovsky's Swan Lake she soon forms
the Rivalry with fellow dancer Lily
played by Mila Kunis and slowly begins
to lose touch with reality at one point
in the film Kunis and Portman's
characters lock themselves in a room and
end up in bed together a scene that was
something of a trial for both actresses
in an interview with parade kudas
revealed that Chi and Portman knew the
scene would be a Hot Topic it wasn't
done for shock value but we weren't
looking forward to it I don't think we
were laughing between takes I think we
were like let's just get this over with
it's uncomfortable doing a sex scene
it's just bizarre Portland can confirmed
this in a conversation with MTV News it
was pretty awkward I almost feel like it
would be easier to do it with someone
you didn't know that said both Portman
and Kunis agreed that their friendship
made the whole process smoother before
Horrible Bosses there was nine to five
this dark comedy from 1980 centered on
three overworked overlooked female
secretaries enacting brutal revenge on a
chauvinistic Pig of a manager played by
Dabney Coleman Dolly Parton Lily Tomlin
and Jane Fonda headed up the cast with
Fonda also producing but a mere week
after filming began Tomlin tried to quit
what set off the legendary comic actress
she watched the raw footage of herself
and was embarrassed by her performance
particularly the scenes for a Snow White
inspired animated fantasy sequence where
she acted opposite a yet to be created
cartoon bird on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert Tomlin explained and I
was talking to the birds that weren't
there yeah yeah and I was not doing a
good job and I thought oh this is I'm
gonna be horrible in this despite her
reservations she's stuck with the film
and an 80s classic was born
during production of the first fast and
furious movie series regular and
all-around badass Michelle Rodriguez
actually considered walking away over
concerns with the way her character
buddy Ortiz was written specifically
Rodriguez took issue with the way the
script called for Letty to portray her
true love Dom and fall for undercover
cop Brian she felt this betrayal made no
sense for a woman who clearly preferred
in her words the alphaist of alpha males
to a pretty boy refusing to compromise
her vision of Letty Rodriguez put her
foot down telling producers she'd quit
the movie if she had to fortunately for
Fast and Furious fans the storyline was
tweaked to Rodriguez's liking and the
rest is Blockbuster history Marvel's The
Avengers was such a huge ambitious
project that it attracted actors who
usually don't do comic book movies
including two-time Oscar nominee Jeremy
renner's Hawkeye while some of the more
famous heroes in the movie got to do
more interesting things Hawkeye spent
most of the Avengers as the brainwashed
servant of villain Loki this didn't
please remember during a q a event she
said I was just getting to know who
Hawkeye was and then zap I go round like
a zombie I'm like Loki's minion Renner
claimed that he wanted to give the crew
an easy out for Hawkeye so he pretended
to have a heart attack while cameras
rolled in a number of scenes he
explained to the filmmakers I'm giving
you an option if you just want to kick
me out of this movie just you know at
any given moment if you want to kill me
off Daddy's going to be having a heart
attack
foreign